welcome to screen jumping central from
San Diego it's time for movie fights
brought to you by the new Samsung
Chromebook plus the first Chromebook may
for Google Play and now here's your host
Andy signor oh my god hello 4:38 over
here oh I'm so excited we have amazing
fight for you right now I don't want to
do without further ado how great there
we have we have two amazing fighters Dan
are you what are you thinking here I did
have a thought what well you know
Kevin's great yes
Eliza's great yeah I've bought both of
them yeah they beat you they beat me I'm
on a revenge tour this year do you want
to take a lie let me take these two on
what do you guys think their show it's
their show all right let me do it let's
see we now you're fighting I'm going to
need a fact checker do I look fact
checker oh I was just walking around
with my Samsung Chromebook man to have a
nest effect test
perfect timing illusion would you bang
my head sure thing hi Baby Bop with
these guys guys this is insane I've been
dreaming for this fight ever since they
both came on let's do it first up
filmmaker legend mentor I mean I just
used so many things to me such a
wonderful filmmaker ladies and gentlemen
Oh Kevin you're going up and what a
wonderful fellow this guy is amazing
actors such amazing film lover such a
wonderful guy you know master wonderful
person Elijah Wood
[Applause]
guys this is going to be a fight am i
right all right I saw it guys now you've
both been on you know other show work
and I'm such a fan of you because you
both love movies I know you know how
this game works you take it seriously
you love your movies and we have some
epic movies that we're going to be
revealing throughout this fight to stay
tuned are you guys ready I'm so ready oh
man I'm so ready I just want to say and
I want to thank our sponsor Samsung and
their new Chromebook plus the first
Chromebook made for Google Play Thank
You Samsung for helping these are so
nice looking you guys know how this
works let's do it music
[Music]
that downside Oh fine time yes all right
we have some really really tough fights
here let's do this question one who's
the greatest living film maker
it was so hard not to write Kevin Smith
Dan let's just go down the line what are
you picking I chose mr. Martin Scorsese
Elijah what are you picking Steven
Spielberg Kevin Smith this is where
things could get a little controversial
Andy I chose a Marvel mastermind Kevin
Feige ah
I made you think yes that's what I chose
you start there Kevin you can start the
fight somebody begin well it depends how
one defines the question what is it
technically whose greatest living
filmmaker filmmaker isn't just the
director and let's be honest in most
cases it's never just the director
usually there's a different screenwriter
in the world of a comic book
storytelling it's the people that do
some of the heaviest lifting don't even
go to set and meet the actors man they
do zeros and ones on laptops and stuff
to create a moving effect so I'm not
taking anything away from the other from
every single filmmaker of each Marvel
film they each have an individual sound
clearly the director and writers behind
each have a voice and an phenomenal job
I've overpaid to see them many many
times but Kevin Feige is the guy who
captured the ship Kevin Feige like even
though he's not going action and cut has
plotted how many phases of movies and
not just movies and that'll be my
argument like what is a filmmaker if not
somebody who self expresses in a way
that changes you and you're watching the
experience and it can be fictional
doesn't have to be this is a guy who
makes movies and again he may might be
the guy going action cut but he is the
person plotting all these he makes
movies at me at age 46
b-47 next week as an over middle-aged
man thank you with less time in front of
me than behind me and stuff and it's
somebody who have the works in the
sausage factory knows how the sausage is
made even though they make good sausage
and I make [ __ ] McDonald's sausage in
[ __ ] even though even though I have that
perspective I can still walk into a
Marvel movie and absolutely be
transported even better not they make me
feel like I did when I went to see Star
Wars when when I was a kid or Raiders of
the Lost Ark they dial my cloth bag and
anybody who can tell me a story and make
me feel young I'll pay you real money if
you can give me the Fountain of Youth
you can but this guy can with his
storytelling and even though he's not
the one going like I'm going to touch
this key touch this key I'm going to
print up the script myself he's telling
the stories he's mapping it out in many
ways kind of the largest filmmaker
working right now Elijah
get in this comparative not filmmaking
huh man it's a machine
- I didn't filmmaking I agree I like
certainly the people behind the scenes
are as much a part of that process and
it isn't just the director absolutely
right and it's everyone along the way I
see the machinery in Marvel though man I
I feel like I see a production line and
I see release dates I don't see fully
cooked ideas or fully cooking ideas
before they go to the screen only not
like those Rings movies or anything
forget about The Hobbit so in a monadic
oh no no no the Rings movies the ones
about a little Ora girl in jail like
that
right what were you thinking haha anyway
but not so not necessarily debate that
so Steven Spielberg right look this was
a really difficult question who's the
greatest living filmmaker doesn't
there's so many different ways that you
can slice this pie initially I went to
you know modern filmmakers someone like
Paul Thomas Anderson came to my head but
like who if you think about people who
are still alive and still relevant
Steven Spielberg oh hey buddy
but even silver from from our from our
you would it be our you like well
everybody Cooper but like if someone who
has influenced the way that we see
modern cinema yeah there's no question
that Steven Spielberg has done that the
the notion of a modern blockbuster was
was sort of established because of jaws
and you know he's also cross genres he's
he's made so many films that are
indelible in cinema and as broken ground
and even now like you may not love every
single film that he does a but there
there's craftsmanship there and he's
still relevant he's still pushing
himself as a filmmaker and I honestly
can't think of anybody more deserving of
that title alright Dan superior take
quick torsades and it will start this
fight I mean you know me I'm still bird
guy I love Spielberg I love Marvel
movies but when I think about the
greatest living filmmaker I when I when
I think the word filmmaker I think of
Martin Scorsese cuz Martin Scorsese he's
like he's got his he's got his eye on
the camera he's sitting there he is
cutting the frames and he's sitting
there with in the dark room and he not
he absolutely has an editor's in Selma
Schumacher eventually cut in the frame
he's there though he popped in for
coffees like that looks good he was
never coming on songs but knowing what
he means is when they're in the editing
room cutting on the avid he's actually
just back there with old world reels of
film just to make anybody you like the
old days I'm are helping they're like
that's great I'm beginning with a
hands-on filmmaker I'm saying he's a
hands-on filmmaker but what the greatest
living filmmakers that this guy's been
in the game for almost
50 years and he's still doing stuff like
go look at what he did with Hugo like
here's great Oh grandpa's got the 3d
machine he's not even know how to use
that thing
that thing was amazing was brilliant as
an oscar-nominated film he's able to
make anyway that was the title in Italy
grandpa has led by the shitty machine
look at a director of this stage making
a movie like the wolf of Wall Street
which is still vibrant as the movies he
made 40 years ago the guy lives and
breathes film not to mention the fact
that he's a movie encyclopedia you can
ask him any movie you guess about the
silent film from FW Murnau in 1912 and
he will tell you the filmography like
the guys lives and breathes film and
every movie it's not just one that he
produced or one that that he directed
off of you know some great like a great
book like Spielberg is great at taking
big ideas making the big on scream like
this guy it's just like he puts his
heart and soul into every single movie
he's been put in the hospital overdoing
movies and he's been great for almost 50
years and he's still going to be great I
think that's always the greatest living
so Megan Wow
all right now why is why is yours the
best one more last round this is the
fight now why it's Feige better than
Spielberg or Z this is really the battle
here I can't say that foggy is better
than the Spielberg War Scorsese when you
put them up to directors against a guy
who's a producer but when we talk about
film makers and they can stand
shoulder-to-shoulder again you're
talking about somebody Martin Scorsese
has had how many years 50 years come
about become laughter yeah and some
stuff you know along the way wasn't
necessarily that masterful and stuff you
learn your craft as you're going along
but he's at 50 years - how dare you say
that about seven years in Tibet I didn't
even mention names duh and and Steven
Spielberg a filmmaker of course I do 11
I totally agree with the argument that
or point that this is a guy who created
the modern day blockbuster he a
wonderful storyteller fantastic and I
would make the argument that they are
two of the greatest directors on the
planet but a filmmaker goes beyond just
the person who is like I think it would
be cool if we did this or the person
who's like hey I read a great script and
I think I can bring something to it I
think I can elevate if at the very least
execute
something you're talking about somebody
who in a short period of time my guy
Kevin Feige has been plotting an entire
run of movies just on the back of one it
starts very quietly with Iron Man and
the gamble begins there where if this
works we can keep going there are
multiple phases and they're planning
this thing a decade of doing it 10 years
how many Marvel movies have been made so
far in 10 years a lot there you go and I
know Martin Scorsese has made a lot of
movies but and I'm not saying quantity
over quality but for me in terms of a
filmmaker and figuring out what an
audience wants to watch and enjoy and
interact with something I clearly can't
do in my own career I still think that
this isn't worry don't cry for me
Argentina I still think that this is a
person that to me my again I'm going by
the question which was filmmaker
somebody who has to put together an
entire film I'm a director and I know
what I'm responsible for why is that
better though than these two quickly why
is it better oh hey Tom what you said
based on filmmaker that's a broader term
broader term and and a filmmaker can get
a movie made a director can always get a
movie made and sometimes when the
director makes a film he can't even get
it done correctly but a filmmaker can
all the filmmakers job is from beginning
down and make sure there's a movie so I
make sure I understand for that because
you guys can help me vote here you're
doing your talking because he's building
this broader universe there's a bigger
sort of piece and these one-at-a-time
stories is that what I'm gathering for
yeah that's that's filmmaking filmmaker
filmmaking God we're telling that's a
lot of story to tell ok Elijah why do
you have what do you feel like that's
verified you to put them next to
Spielberg and/or Scorsese man I love the
fact that you've broadened the argument
I really genuinely love it and and I
just wanted to bring the argument I know
I'm going to lose you're so right
you're so right but I would I would
argue that that both Spielberg and
Scorsese are filmmakers underneath that
same banner in the sense of they're not
simply directors both of them are ideas
people they fully develop with you know
a variety of creative teams very
hands-on in the the construction and the
cooking of those films so complete and
total filmmakers certainly not directors
for hire at this point it's a personal
opinion that I feel that under this
particular banner that Steven Spielberg
is the greatest living filmmaker but I
love your argument better than Scorsese
it would give me one a better than
scores right if we just ignore Kevin per
second no offense yes certainly so
because I just want to get one last
thought for your the uh um in terms of
leaving a mark on cinema I would argue
that he absolutely has made a much
larger mark on cinema now a better
larger more significant and one that
some people just like the right size and
I think we've been married a long time
so I know she's sorry Andrew Dan what do
you think against these two I think the
Kevin Feige recruits great filmmakers I
think that he actually learned with age
of Ultron that when he's too hands-on in
his capacity as a producer sometimes he
could lose the ball because I think that
Joss Whedon's kind of said to Kevin
Feige with him and said you're putting
the source stuff in age of Ultron and
that was when people said like I'm not
so sure about that you're kind of losing
the ball and it's from that point on
that he said you know what you're right
I'm going to get these great filmmakers
like Ryan Coogler and Tyco YTD to do my
future movies and I'm going to be the
guy that kind of lets them do their
thing and keeps an eye on the overall
picture um so I think that he's great at
finding great filmmakers to go and make
films for him and for the brand I think
that Spielberg look John's my favorite
movie I love Spielberg I just think if
you look at recent I think that the last
10-15 years Spielberg has kind of I
don't know if he's innovated a lot I
think that he's kind of he puts out a
new Spielberg movie that did you see the
trailer for really Blair and when ready
player one comes out I never send this
statement but I'm just more today like
it's like dad went away for a few years
and came back as like I said look at my
huge dick and everybody in Hall H was
like we were member but people have to
remember I think BFG is just like what
I'm Steven Spielberg being Wednesday's
was its whimsy just just be enchanted
and I feel like Scorsese is continuing
to innovate and learn and grow as a
filmmaker he's adapting and he's
evolving and I think that's what makes a
great filmmaker all right Wow
good birth all right you guys Elise from
Kentucky you guys have cards you're
gonna help me vote one of them you're
going to lift your hand for one you're
going to blue for the other you can do
white for the other Alicia while they
get their cards or anything to add I was
clean fight
well we'll fault you guys I loved seeing
Dan try and fight against against
Gilberg because I know how much you love
us bill back in time in like a week no
but just some little facts to add it is
actually Marco says he's 50th year this
year of directing his first movie was in
1967 edited by Selma shoemaker who he's
worked with consistently and been a
great collaborator and Marvel as
spider-man homecoming is the 16th film
for Marvel but so many now years right
it's the only a decade yeah yeah all
right there we go to the vote hear it
you're going to do blue for Dan white
for Kevin or hand in your air for Elisha
understand very high tech blue lifts
them up blue for Dan white for Kevin or
hand for Elijah I see a lot of hands
alright just to verify all right it's
white in hand so it's between there's a
hockey town let's say whites between
these two okay
I wasn't a lot of Blues all right put
the hands down sorry just help me blue
for Kevin white for Elijah
wait that's confused because when I was
white so did she call it whether they
like to get the point
harder with three but I would definitely
there were a lot of hands I know this is
really just round workouts aren't easy
it start actually super yes yet I'm
going to bill allies we go to the third
and moly [ __ ] go for it at the end
and you you said you were going to lose
never say that on movie fight I hated an
express a sentiment that seems largely
in vogue and tired but I think this
election was rigged all right round two
what is the best comic what comic book
movie of all time will be most
celebrated in 50 years it's got to be a
movie that's now today that we know that
we think 50 years from now will be the
most celebrated and we're going this
time to Kevin no it's sorry to Elijah
first oh they're giving you to go it's
dark tonight but the reason I chose this
on is I think that it's a a movie that
is beloved regardless of whether or not
you're a fan of comic books I think it
works both as an incredible comic book
film and as a great piece of cinema not
to say that those things have to be
separated because they are inherently
not within the context of a movie but
you don't have to have a pre-existing
knowledge of Batman or love of Batman I
think to love that movie and I think
that's why it will stand the test of
time I think you know there was a sort
of thing that happened with that film
after it was released where there were a
lot of films that felt like they needed
to follow the same path that Nolan did
which is a sort of dark nihilism that
kind of permeated comic book movies a
little bit after that and that was a bit
of a bummer because I don't think that
they were inherent within the
storytelling of those other films that
followed sue
however that particular movie it was the
best version of the Joker I've ever seen
unquestionably
it worked as a detective film in a way
that sort of as a recall to Batman of
old and the comic books certainly the
the heist scene at the opening is one of
the greatest [ __ ] openings of film in
the last 20 years I just think it's
going to be remembered look there are so
many incredible movies being made in the
comic book genre certainly with Marvel
and
give it a good try but when they well I
haven't seen Wonder Woman so it sounds
great I know I'm working on them I
really want to see it but I just think
this is what this is a movie that will
be remembered again regardless of this
period of time that we're in which is so
heavy and you know beautifully saturated
with a lot of great offerings in regards
to comic book films I just think that
movie will will stand out dan what are
you picking it's the newest but this is
legit I actually did I did pick Wonder
Woman I think that even though this is
the movie of our time so you know it's
hard to say what the legacy of a movie
especially one that's just out but I
think if you look at it first and
foremost it is a hell of a good movie I
mean I think it is up there with as far
as like telling expressing to an
audience what the superhero is about and
who they are not as a hero but like as a
person I think it's up there with the
Iron Man and Christopher Reeve Superman
as far as like this is the hero that you
that you read in the comic books and
this is what they're about and and
people yes I like that so I think it's a
hell of a great movie secondly I think
it's got a legacy of when you look at
what patty Jenkins did with that movie
and the fact that like Elijah said going
into it people's like oh well I don't
know about these DC things the fact that
if DC goes forward and I hope that they
do and and succeeds and does
tremendously as well as Marvel does I
think people are going to look at Wonder
Woman as the moment that had changed and
then secondly just from the records that
it said from a female director the
blockbusters this big doing that kind of
business with a female director that's
that's a wall that some people said
couldn't be broken so I feel like even
if there are other Wonder Woman movies
and even if the greater context of the
superhero environment they were in now
is lost in the decades to come I think
that that barrier being broken and that
group of creators gal gadot and patty
Jenkins and and and everybody involved
with that movie coming together and
saying you're wrong I think people are
still going to remember that in the
decades to come so that's why I picked
order one Kevin what are you picking I
go guardians of the galaxy ladies
gentlemen
here is my rationale behind that I'm a
huge Batman fan naturally I wanted to
pick Dark Knight but I thought about an
awful lot what is the exact question
again what comic book movie of our time
will be most celebrated in 50 years and
that was where I stumbled on the in 50
years part and I thought about all the
comic book movies that I've seen over
the course of say the last 10 years or
even my lifetime and the one that feels
the most like a movie that ages well is
guardians it reminds me of Wizard of Oz
if you would have seen Wizard of Oz for
the first time in the 50s and stuff and
you watched it 50 years later as like an
old person you probably have the same
feeling of wonder there's a sense of
timelessness to it in terms of like Oz
is like no place you've ever seen just
like the space the galaxy that the
guardians take us to her James Gunn and
Kevin Feige take us to was a place of
wonder that you'd never seen before what
should a movie do it should transport
you you should escape from where you are
in the real world it should make you
think it should make you feel you should
be able to walk out of there with useful
information for your daily life that's
what storytelling comes down to we all
started telling each other stories you
know to help each other not die look
don't eat that you'll die you know
here's a story about herb that did it
and [ __ ] like that
so the storytelling that we see on
display here is to me like truly what
movies are supposed to be and I'm a guy
that's supposed to make movies for a
living but when I sit down watch the
Guardians I'm like I am transported oh
my god we're in a world with talking
trees and talking raccoons and stuff and
in terms of like strong role models I
love Wonder Woman death but Gomorrah is
also a really strong role model with a
way deeper more interesting background
and and in terms of like the
relationship the heart of that movie
that's what's going to go a long way I
love the dark 9 I love Wonder Woman and
stuff but I don't think of those movies
of having as having sick gooey beating
hearts that will thunder throughout time
I'm not saying they're movies of their
moment but when you think about
guardians of the galaxy and is dying
they oh boy lers they open the movie
with his dying mom saying Peter take my
hand
and then they pay that off you know as
he's holding the Infinity stone and the
Morrises Peter take my image he sees his
mom again
that's the kind of [ __ ] I don't care how
old you are and what decade you're in it
will go right to your heart man so I'm
picking guardians of the galaxy about
age insanely well are the fans like all
three of these all right as we close
there your next rounds here tell me why
yours is going to be most remembered
celebrated in 50 years well I'm with
Kevin it was the end 50 years part that
that hung me up and that's one other
thing that led me to Wonder Woman was I
think that spurred to be celebrated in
50 years I think it has to be a timeless
movie and there's certain elements to it
being timeless The Dark Knight is a
great movie but I feel like even now 10
years later there are some things the
surveillance angle that were very timely
now that now kind of stick out like a
sore thumb I think in guardians of the
galaxy there are there's a lot of great
comedic parts but I think there are also
some pop-culture references in that
movie that in 50 years aren't going to
mean as much as they do to us now and I
think that's going to lose some of its
value over time I think that Wonder
Woman is a timeless story it's already
set in the for what is uh for us the
distant past and I think the themes of
that movie as far as finding who you are
in the world and and the nature of
humanity and and where does evil come
from those are timeless themes I think
they're going to be as relevant in 50
years as they are today and that's what
led me to Wonder Woman it's not so much
that these movies aren't great it's that
I think that there seems and there are
things in Wonder Woman beyond what it
did culturally that will resonate still
in 50 years
Alijah oh man this is hard you guys well
I think look I think the as far as
timeless is concerned you know there are
plenty of movies that are 50 years old
that are not relevant technologically to
our world now that are timeless in
regards to the characters that are
inherent within the context of the film
so you know that argument against the
Dark Knight doesn't hold that much water
for me to me I think it's it's a great
ultimately the center of that story is a
man that's kind of in crisis based on
his past and the trauma of his past and
ultimately becoming the hero that God
some needs them to be and kind of
sailing at that and and coming up
against ultimate chaos it's something
that we can relate to their their their
human characters at play in a pretty
massive way in this city and I think
they're they're they're they're tortured
characters that that we love and can
kind of relate to and understand and I
think I don't know man they're still
making in that the other thing that I
wanted to mention earlier about it is
that it's not a movie that for better or
worse and I think ultimately for better
it does not rely on the fact that it's a
comic book film it presents itself as a
movie and again I'm not saying that
don't I know and I'm not reading the
question go I'm like he didn't [ __ ]
read the question no I don't it better
be a comic book well I need the comic
book film but I don't want to I don't
want to disparage the notion of a comic
book film that's not what I'm saying
it's that it's the idea of making
something if let's say you're not a fan
of something and you make it based on
pure reasons because you've discovered
the source material not because of your
reverence to the source material
I think greatness comes out of that and
I don't know that Nolan was a comic book
nerd I think he approached it from it
from a different standpoint and it
didn't have the there's a there's a
level of a lack of preciousness of comic
books and just simply approaching it
from a character standpoint that I
thought made a more interesting film hmm
Kevin wrapping up yours I feel like I'm
a little in shaky ground here oh no I
think it's valid here here's my argument
I'm not going to disavow these two
movies I love them dearly and stuff but
these two movies are stories about
singular journeys
I like guarding the galaxy because it's
a team it's finding out strength in
numbers it's finding out we can't do
this alone
it's personal philosophy of mine we're
all in this together for heaven's sakes
why not lean on one another often we
isolate quite like The Dark Knight
do things by ourselves and we see how it
works out for him and stuff the notion
of leaning on others of coming together
and yes there's a band of merry makers
who help Wonder Woman ultimately achieve
her goal but
her goal I mean I enjoy that movie but I
don't know in 50 years if the third act
of that movie is going to play as well
with people going why is it so dark
who's fighting and [ __ ] like that like
ending goes pretty Zack Snyder there and
in terms of the dart of the Dark Knight
I honestly feel like you know Batman as
a popular character of popular culture
is always a product of his era and while
people respect previous iterations they
kind of live and die right there think
about it like most people talk about
today the late great Adam West's
performance is like oh that's Batman 66
when things were campy but for kids who
grew up watching that there's nothing
can't be about it that was biblical
truth and stuff so you know Batman I'm
Batman as the character ages incredibly
well but those particular iterations I
don't know if they will I don't know I'm
not I'm not saying like oh they'll never
be able to understand them back then but
they're not quite as timeless as a movie
that's like hey let's leave the planet
altogether to a place that will always
be timeless unless we finally go live in
space and we start finding these [ __ ]
raccoons that talk and [ __ ] like that
like it take again I'll argue that it's
a movie and a movie should take you to a
place you've never seen I've seen Gotham
and unfortunately in the history books
I've seen World War 1 but you know I've
never seen know where this giant Titans
head which is mined from the inside by
people who are living off the scraps of
something much larger than themselves
all right Gary sky your time all right
try this again well the other way to
make oh yo Misha yeah anything bad here
I'm so glad that I'm not funny eyes are
amazing but just some little facts so
Rotten Tomatoes if you go by that score
guardians the galaxy 91% Wonderwoman 92%
dark knight 94% and with Academy looking
like one yeah so really nice yeah and
Academy old man those are really good
poll yeah obviously it's too early to
tell whether Wonder Woman will be
nominated but guardians had two Oscar
nominations for makeup hairstyling
visual effects Dark Knight 8 Oscar
nominations of course it won two sound
editing and he
Leger rest in pay I'm going back around
we switch the colors up blue is for
Elijah whites will be for Kevin and your
hand will be for Dan oh that sounds so
dirty blue for a lot
oh man that's white ah I was white Kevin
getting it I agree with that one I
thought you did a really good argument
there at the end of course Kevin gets it
Kevin is walk all right round three what
was garius movie scene of all time all
right you going to scare it Dan we'll
start with you what is the scariest
scene of all time I think we hopefully
have visual aids we tried doing it
visual aids I have max all we do this is
the one that when I saw it it probably
there's nothing Supernatural about it
there's nothing bogeyman jumping out of
the closet about it it's the shower
scene from psycho because I remember I
remember I watched that movie the first
time I was visit my grandmother's house
was on late at night a late night cable
TV this is like you know this wasn't
like in 1975 this is like I don't know
in the 90s but I remember seeing it and
I saw that scene and I knew about the
shower scene in psycho but I'd never
seen it in contact it was kind of like
it like I really like I you know you've
seen parodies of it when you see it in
the context of that movie what makes it
so scary is that for the next there's
still days where I get in the shower and
I'm kind of like that for me that is
what it's scary it's not it's Freddy
Krueger to come get me in my dreams is
am I going to be taking a shower and
then some nut bag is going to stab me to
death because that could happen in a wig
and a dress that's even crazier
once those eyes when they pull the thing
back and you do it and ANSI Perkins
wasn't there you see those eyes staring
us that is freaky man that is freaky so
I went with the one that legitimately
scared me that still creeps me out to
this day it's and it's held up for over
50 years for that exact reason we have
it max go ahead
[Music]
oh wow all right I'm scraping all right
back to you Elijah what are you picking
this is really difficult as all these
[ __ ] questions have been this is a
really hard you guys are like old
fighting you with those beautiful eyes
every time you start talking about like
I like what you're saying right in this
was difficult I basically picked very
almost an opening scene there's a movie
called big gotten by a filmmaker called
Elias marriage Wow I went the story
behind this is I I am how you're gonna
lose my right but like the good fight
kid a lot these people decide Wilson so
I was at a video store and I saw this
film on an end cap I was a virgin
megastore back when they still existed
and oh yeah women do that yeah yeah so
my sister and I saw this thing in the
Gottman it had this black and white
cover that's very disturbing sort of
like ultra grainy imagery that was
clearly a still from the film entirely
what the hell is this and it was from
the filmmaker of shadow of the vampires
that was my curiosity was piqued and we
bought it home we started watching this
movie we got twenty minutes into it and
I couldn't finish it I've never been
able to get this imagery out of my head
I can essentially describe that the
scene is a very it's black and white
super super saturated quite difficult to
tell what's actually happening there's a
man sitting in a chair man woman not
sure stabbing itself and it's really
[ __ ] up it's like a snuff film
and yeah it's the stuff of nightmares
via evidence oh well we have a cliff
well
[Applause]
Wow
what is it called forgotten all right
Kevin your turn
I was gonna head up to ball I'm going to
go with something that is probably most
people are going to be like aw it's so
on the nose
it is the closing scene from Rob Reiner
movie north
the thank you I had two jokes prepared
that was one wait which really works
over here here's the second joke take
two the scariest horror movie scene in
any movie I've ever seen is that the
question has to be the closing moments
of Jersey girl no that's not my joke
okay here's my choice ladies Jim the
real choice move a moment and movie that
terrified me still terrifies me stirred
it to this day it affects me everywhere
I go
jaws was moving to scare me when I was
kids you'd think oh I love jaws go for
jaws but I don't have to go into the
ocean every day in fact I happened since
I saw jaws but what I do have to do is
walk around and whenever I walk around
anywhere and turn a corner of a hallway
I will never not think of Danny on his
on his big wheel going through the
hallways in the Overlook Hotel turning a
corner and finding those two little
Grady girls let's cue it
[Music]
tell me playing with us oh I'll miss it
right now
[Music]
play with us daddy-o all right
three threes good choice and spine it
out fellas
I don't know what elijah's was it didn't
scare me exactly I don't know what it
was very strange how to turn me on to be
honest are the shining I always I admire
that film I think that is like a piece
of like impressionist art and you know
so I see that and I admire the crap that
went into that and that is certainly a
creepy image but like that didn't scare
me in the sense of like I think that's
going to happen to me and that's that's
what scares me the most it's not like oh
wow that's creepy it's like I think that
I am dead like someone could be sneaking
into my bathroom and and and the reason
I think that's even scarier is like
everybody can relate to that everybody
can put yourself in that shoes if
everybody wants to sneak into your
bathroom no leverage is that No
everybody everybody gets in the shower
everybody has that moment in their home
alone you have to get in the shower and
you're like is there someone in the
house with me get somebody sneak in here
and kill me and I think that's what
makes that that that scares so amazing
is like Eddie who hasn't seen that and
has it been like damn that could happen
to me
that reeks me out and that's what free
funerals are people trying to get in
your shower all the time you'd be
surprised
uh but I didn't know I attend Let Me In
do you have pearl I admire the kubrik
thing I think it's a great piece of art
that doesn't scare me like psycho scares
recycle that is primal fear that is a
stranger is going to come to your house
and kill you and that is like the
scariest thing in the world to me Elijah
man how to defend something that not
many people have seen ah they just saw
yeah that like they did yeah did it all
last year where the oh please go ahead
oh man
hmm hmm well my definition of being
afraid
hmm it's slightly different I think it's
about imagery that sticks in my head and
kind of haunts me later
I don't movies don't viscerally scare me
even when I was a kid I didn't see a
film and sort of have it jump in and get
that same feeling it takes a lot to
scare me in a movie but the idea of a
piece of imagery that is difficult to
kind of make out what it is and it but
it feels so sinister and can kind of
live in your psyche and your nightmares
for a very long time that particular
piece of footage that you all thought
does that to me and I can't explain what
it is why it is it's probably more
disturbing that it is scary I realize
I'm slightly stretching the definition
but it freaks me out enough that I had
to turn the DVD off and I couldn't
finish watching the movie so a lot about
these guys today Kevin your turn which
is this be disavowing okay give me your
fight we are closing marks here why is
your scarier than theirs
the I found Elijah's Bank video didn't
scare me as as much as intrigued me like
I want to watch more of that like what's
the context of that scene in terms of
the shower I'm like I'm not nearly as
afraid in the bathroom as you are we're
fighting it to me if we go down the
psychological rabbit hole it's just like
I just don't want people to see my
little dick and like and I get that
because I have no dick whatsoever but I
know that I can lock the bathroom door
damn they put locks on the bathroom door
you live in terror while you're
showering like someone's coming at any
moment anyone but me you're supposed to
the only one coming in the shower man so
I feel like that fear while you're right
we all you know shower some I would
argue some people don't share are some
people bathe they're afraid of showers
and not because of psycho just because
they are not a handle water would you be
afraid of shower if it wasn't for psycho
what other reason would you be afraid of
cuz you're a four year old it's like I
don't understand how it works like I was
so and see you bathe until you're 30
so not everyone necessarily takes a
shower but you can lock a bathroom door
however there
always everywhere in life you can't not
turn a corner man there are no escaping
Li if you're walking someplace and
leaving a room you run the chance of
running into a ghost that's what
terrifies me I won't get stabbed to
death in the shower the likelihood of
that happening nil and none and [ __ ] so
I don't really get scared if you're
going to be a halite is ok put a ghost
in the hallway that could happen that's
all right give them a round of applause
Alesha
what do you got there as we get our vote
Freddie well so - sighs Irish shower
scene 78 setups 52 cuts there's a great
documentary called 7852 with Elijah it's
actually in but I just want to read to
you what happens next the next scene
after hoping the one that Elijah show oh
she doesn't know the film of it okay so
mother earth rises from God's body and
impregnates herself with his semen
before she's later raped by a bunch of
Wanderers who have already attacked her
offspring the son of Earth with what
looks like an umbilical cord I never
want to see this movie it's really great
hoping soon from Marvel Studios alright
great that scares me we're going to do
blue for Dan White for Kevin hand for
Elijah blue for Dan White Wow
I mean that's white again that's a
pretty big one arias foreheads and
movement boy yeah you did you that was a
pretty good argument there Kevin I would
have given that to you I did not like
that argument at all I just like
Round four guys in honor of the 13th
anniversary of the Elijah's wonderful
film Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind right what a good movie
we introduced a fun one we had loosely
based off that if you could permanently
erase one movie from all of existence
which would it be Dan serve essentially
the first movie I watch with my
girlfriend by the way so that's very
special meaning for us that movie so
thank you for doing that movie so I'm
racing it no no my pick was jaws - what
yes and I can't wait to fight on this
one and I will tell you why
yeah boo is right just - really yeah he
wasn't screaming - he would say who and
I'll tell you why it's not because jaws
- is necessarily a terrible movie
they're way worse movies out there than
jaws - but that is a [ __ ] life
philosophy to live like oh well there
you go there you go a lot guys happy
I'll tell you why I picked jaws - in the
same way that jaws pioneered the summer
blockbuster yes
jaws - to me pioneered the modern
methodology as far as Studios go of hey
that did really well and that was a
great movie let's do the same thing
again but worse and then just keep doing
it forever and just to succeed in to the
degree that it did is the reason why we
got so many of these things because
somebody made a great film and instead
of just putting the camera away the
studio said let's just put it remix it
not do it as well does it make any sense
to giant sharks that makes no sense the
only limit less sense is three and the
only thing that makes less than is four
and the only thing we got three and four
is because he had to that's why you
blink jaws - our resistance maybe we
have a few less transformers is out
there and if you let these terrible
Wow all right Elijah what are you
picking after that sermon there it is
Jesus preach but that's all it is it's a
sermon is empty is religion we'll get
there
go ahead wow this is heating up
I chose tim burton's
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory most
remakes inherently don't justify their
existence there are many exceptions to
that and I think if you're making a
remaking a film oftentimes it's to make
something new or to to have a completely
new interpretation some kind of I don't
know you're trying to improve make
something better than what had come
before or at least adds something to it
that film did none of that if anything
it destroyed the book and it destroyed
the original film it contained no magic
the thing about Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory as I'm sure all of you
have seen and loved it's all about magic
you you ultimately don't fully trust
Willy Wonka as a character but you do
have some faith that he's leading you in
the right direction
there's questionable behavior but
there's still something inherently
magical about him you love him on some
level the version of Willy Wonka in Tim
Burton's film is heinous and terrifying
and molesty and strange there's there's
nothing pure beautiful about it and they
mean they took it's a bold move like
he'd very much took it in his own
direction but I think he missed the mark
and uh it's yeah it's a terribly
disturbing unhappy film and happy Kevin
what's happening what do you pit well
all right yeah there's there like at me
it's Kevin what are you picking this is
a hard one and not because I like to
keep like a general peace in the world
but I'm a storyteller and I know there's
no film no movie that should be blanked
out of existence that's somebody's self
expression about who they are about
where they lived about what they went
through and so for me it was really like
tough of course there are movies that
I've seen that I've not like I
completely forgot about that one and
stuff so right away I was again I'm
moving kind of blue but uh but I I kind
of went deep cuts on this and and also I
went beyond the obvious the question was
exactly what again if you could I can't
see her manelli erase one movie from all
existence which would it be okay so the
movie I chose is Leni Riefenstahl
triumph of the will I know it's not like
whoa because no one's everyone's like
what the [ __ ] is that movie but it was a
movie that was made at the past of Adolf
Hitler for Hitler to glorify the Third
Reich so I'll be honest with you I chose
that because I knew I would win the game
on that because there's no way someone's
going to not vote against the Nazi movie
so I'll let you guys have at it with
your jaws - and your willy wonka's and
I'll be here talking about real matters
and Elijah would you like a reply I
can't win boys I came to win
so tonight damn it's a losing
proposition here's why Hitler was okay
versus jaws - I'm going to try to thread
this needle Kevin - go ahead do it I'm
going to walk I'm along on this journey
with me if you will I will MA dirty so
excited okay Charlie's Chocolate Factory
first of all I'll tell you I wouldn't
blink out of existence leave thats the
one you got to take out have one I'll
knock I'll tell you something that makes
that make people appreciate Gene Wilder
more and anything that makes you
appreciate you Wilder more I can't say I
would blink out of a desire wasn't
bleeping arlov a guy over time other
Hitler movie now the Hitler movie Hitler
was an [ __ ] and he lost and that's
great for humanity and society Star Wars
is amazing and if you didn't have to
later - well subject if you didn't have
triumph in the will Hitler still would
have lost but we wouldn't have had that
amazing last scene in Star Wars for a
new hope and that's an incredible scene
so that theme was worth six million
losses
nothing he bought a Nazi movie to accrue
to a Hollywood fight or a comic I'm
going on fight so he's got a Nazi movie
- a comic-con movie fight so create
what's the position in here that
gentlemen [ __ ] all you want this is
completely on brand because this is the
ultimate Kobayashi Maru figure your way
out of this one the ship's going down
and [ __ ] alright final [ __ ] Elijah
security or everyone except in this
I look I've been struggling with angles
like it was a propaganda movie it's not
really at MIT was a movie it's a movie
there's no way around it
now you win how can I argue that a
remake of Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory it's got to be a race um all
right and I say that I think the
Transformers form might be worse than
Kevin's pick we're running in a time so
I gotta go straight to this vote here we
go
blue brick for Dan White white that's
fitting white for Kevin hand per Elijah
Oh Kevin win I would like to file a
formal complaint that was a travesty so
don't hate the player hate the [ __ ]
game man like wow I'm on a roll and I'm
just glad that rounds over all right
guys Dan Majerle screening so sir I got
that out of the last but really we were
walking on stage and he's like a lot of
you barely talk like Danny pick Josue
Kepler just wing it just whatever he
says to start you against it yeah I make
lists and learn all right guys Kevin
Elijah you're in the speed round Kevin's
up by two three - Kevin one - Elijah I
have three quick speed rounds this is a
lot of all these frequent questions came
from fans on Twitter brought to you by
Samsung in their new Chromebook plus the
first Chromebook made for Google Play
Thank You Samsung all right you guys
will have 20 seconds each and then
ten-second rebuttals
you'll have to answer quickly I
amendment the first question here comes
from Bradley brunette up from the
Samsung vote online and this is a fun
one I'm going to give you two choices
first one to say it gets it if you don't
you get the other one make sense yes
better movie sidekick Samwise Gamgee or
Jay Jay but to be fair I just say that
out loud every 20 minutes so that wasn't
my answer all right
so better sidekick Jay of Jay and Silent
Bob or Sam white Seok Elijah you have
Samwise
Kevin you have Jay Kevin you went first
look here at you're out of this your
[ __ ] knees out wait don't
don't act like you're sad about it now
all right ready
twenty seconds when you begin Kevin
first me yeah 20 seconds let me tell you
something about Jay
he's real damn wise is a lovely little
fictional character you know the gayest
of the hobbits and and a guy you want on
your side if you're in a fake world of
little people and wizards but if you're
in the real world the hard mean streets
of New Jersey you want somebody whose
rider died somebody's got your back no
matter what
and Jay in both movies and in real life
is pretty much my first and only wife so
I speak from experience not from a guy
who's watched movies or read some books
Jay is hands-down the best all right oh
I was I'm going to give you more time
Elijah go ahead that's fine I don't mind
Samwise Gamgee is the epitome the
embodiment of unconditional love you
know what what more do you want a
sidekick then someone who will be there
for you when you are at your worst
as Frodo is descending into the depths
of what state what's overtaking him in
regards to the ring
Sam wide Samwise doesn't lead aside I
can't think of a more of a better
stronger more courageous sidekick than
that
all right you have ten seconds Kevin
follow final ten seconds go again
Samwise was played by Sean Astin I
believe and I'm sure Sean Astin's a fine
friend in real life but Jay is real ten
seconds Elijah
don't heal with there's no [ __ ]
Eagles to rescue you now but Jay is a
representative of Jay in the film so
he's a fictionalized version of Jay in
the film is he not no no that is okay
okay
as friend and filmmaker action right now
five seconds so still a representation
of a great friendship either way
representation being from a fictional
place or nonfiction place all right
there we go blue for Kevin white for
Elijah Elisha help me here I see a lot
of why I see a lot of white that was
Elijah all I am supplying our stuff man
he is that's Toki and he's got a lot of
years on me and [ __ ] J's is a little
weed dealer even I shouldn't pick second
all right all right the 20th anniversary
had won honor of Elijah I want to do one
here not on Kevin 20th anniversary of
Kevin's chasing a me so this comes from
Jedi Donatello again from the Samsung
poll what which other franchise would
most benefit from the addition of Jay
and Silent Bob of all the any franchise
in the world how would you which bring
art into the galaxy
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Bob never surrendered if you want
to ring tonight whether they told me to
like 70 today if you want to win just
say one of them Rings movies open-floor
the ring Lord of the Rings oh I'll be
the Hobbit on it Dom it that matters not
in that one did you pick learn the Rings
or hob the Hobbit oh ha bit okay I'll
let you touch mine alright Hobbit vs.
Guardians you have 20 you're 30 seconds
Kevin who's going and why Jay and Bob
belong in there yeah well which
franchise would benefit would benefit
from the addition here we go okay
Michael Rooker huge part of the
guardians of the galaxy as spoilers 5 4
3 2 1 not in it anymore because his
character died Michael Rooker was in
Mallrats next to Jay and Silent Bob so
they're next in line after Rooker goes
away Plus it'd be fun to see him in
space floating around touching their
balls yet Elijah why would Sam why would
James on Bob benefit being in The Hobbit
I just think it'd be great at you know
when when there are so many battles that
are happening at the end of the third
movie where you cease to understand what
the [ __ ] going on anymore to have
those two [ __ ] guys running
commentary and sort of being super
[ __ ] confused like we all were as
well oh my god that would have helped
Wow playing to win 10 seconds - Kevin I
really want to see this version of those
movies now this is suddenly looking down
through a whole new prison what was my
argument
time's up ten seconds Eliza I said my
leg oh that's that point yes vote on
that one Kevin but we are tied it isn't
the last question this is it for all the
marbles
three two three wow what a fight then is
this crazy yeah what you said no you're
fine
what all right when honour of comic-con
the abroad one you'll have a second what
classic or iconic movie would inspire it
doesn't already have one what classic
are iconic ones would inspire the best
comic-con like its own comic-con Flash
Gordon I have them have come rut Lord
the Rings ones the Dark Crystal
it's hard
ah he's kinda nervous there to the
growlithe I thought I heard in the bag
I'm going to lose to a Muppet movie
they'll give up all right it's all for
the marble to Europe first Flash Gordon
Kevin time starts when you begin
speaking Flash Gordon look man the
influence this movie is still felt down
through the decades have you seen the
trailer for Thor Ragnarok it owes its
existence to the Flash Gordon movie man
Flash Gordon is a franchise been around
since it was black and white but that
movie that they did the goofy campy one
and what not with the queen flash ah you
could dress up like any one of those
characters you stick your hand in boxes
and [ __ ] like that
Paul people could be minc'd yes Elijah
20 seconds can you read it can I change
my argument I can't change it if you lay
eggs you tell you the [ __ ] Muppet
movie you're gonna take time to change
it can I see if Kevin will allow it I'm
okay James Bond oh right on
I like that I like it better because
they didn't like it well that was a good
move but Kevin allowed it so I'll allow
it James Bond you have 20 seconds and
you've got also decades represented in
the context of James Bond imagine the
cosplay I mean obviously there's just
James Bond but Bond girls the vehicles
the martinis I don't know man I think it
would be incredible I would love the
immersive experience of essentially
going to a place like this for a weekend
and living in the world of James Bond
all right 10 seconds final 10 seconds
make them count keV Hey ladies you want
to come to a con where you're going to
be objectified
and come on down the bonk on Aliza 10
seconds oh he's got it he's like in one
Kevin
[Applause]
I'm so impressed with your film on so
you're such wonderful people thank you
for supporting the show and all the
amazing things you guys do or such big
fan how about this how cool
thank you guys I love you both for doing
this Dan Merle Bravo good job sir Alicia
Malone I love you too protective job
singer helping on Tibet guys okay and
thank you all for watching this has been
movie freud's live for prejudging
central San Diego and guess what Kevin
you one suspect row Bravo sir thank you
for watching we'll see you next year
here
we'd like to thank our sponsor the new
Samsung Chromebook plus for sponsoring
today's episode
you